[Música]
si te falta energía
probablemente sea porque no estás
haciendo las cosas que te entusiasman
me dijo un médico hace exactamente diez
años cuando le fui a pedir que me recete
vitaminas porque me sentía un poco
cansado
un poco desmotivado
y entonces me dijo la frase que me
cambió la vida me dijo la energía viene
de hacer las cosas que nos entusiasman
me acuerdo que en esa época trabajaba
mucho de algo que me gustaba poco la
verdad entonces llegaba tarde a casa y
no me quedaba nada de tiempo ni para la
música ni para la escritura las dos
cosas que más me gustan hacer en la vida
entonces era como que vivía
prácticamente al margen de mi impulso
creativo y de mis ideas que iban
quedando ahí como olvidadas en el camino
no pero yo me acuerdo que en aquella
época lo naturalizada un poco porque
pensaba no sé siempre hay cosas más
importantes que hacer y quién no ha
pospuesto su creatividad por cuestiones
más urgentes
lo cierto es que a todos nos gustaría
tener una idea convertirla en un
proyecto
desarrollarla sin embargo no siempre
tenemos la posibilidad de conectarnos
con nuestras ideas y dejar que no se
enciendan
ahora no sé si vieron que hay gente
creativa que hace lo que le gusta tiene
ideas las realiza por ejemplo está el
que ve una oportunidad y la convierte en
un emprendimiento o el que arranca con
un trazo y pinta un cuadro o el que oye
una melodía y compone una canción como
hacen
es un tema que me fascina
particularmente desde el día en que
aquel doc me dijo esa frase así que me
empecé a preguntar por qué algunos
pueden y otros no qué clase de habilidad
tienen las personas que hacen lo que les
gusta que tienen ideas que las realizan
y que pueden superar los obstáculos que
van apareciendo no pero por sobre todo
de dónde sacan el tiempo y la energía
para hacerlo
los estudie conversé con creativos y
creativas de todos los ámbitos músicos
filósofos poetas pintores psicólogos y
hasta pude contactarme con uno de los
ingenieros más cercanos a steve jobs que
me dijo algo así como que él organiza su
agenda
fundamentalmente en base al entusiasmo
me parece un enfoque muy original y muy
poderoso solemos pensar en cuánto
entusiasmo nos generan las cosas que
hacemos
miren cuando uno habla con una persona
creativa y le pregunta acerca de sus
ideas lo que sucede casi automáticamente
es que la persona se enciende y entonces
en ese momento yo aprovechaba y les
preguntaba como asiste pero muchas veces
me encontraba con respuestas un tanto
abstractas no como de tipo no sé yo
funcionó así o me conecto con la
inspiración o hay una musa que baja y me
habla y yo fluyo y todo ese tipo de
cuestiones que están buenísimas pero la
verdad es que a mí no me alcanzaban
porque seamos sinceros todos en algún
momento de nuestra vida nos conectamos
con algo fluimos con algo oímos una
vocecita que nos dice intentando sin
embargo no siempre tenemos la
posibilidad de conectarnos con esa parte
creativa a cada uno de nosotros tenía
que haber algo más así que sigue
investigando y sigue buscando
hasta el día en que creo que encontré la
respuesta en el lugar menos pensado
en el kárate un arte marcial que
práctico desde que tengo cinco años
primero con el sensei hamamoto y luego
con mi padre
ambos tienen un temple especial
es como si llevaran en la mirada la
clave de algo que el resto no sabemos yo
le digo que es como la mirada del señor
miyagi vieron como mira señor mira y así
como super enfocado bueno una cosa así
pero volviendo a las personas creativas
cierto día me di cuenta que las personas
que tienen ideas y las pueden realizar
superando los obstáculos también tienen
ciertas habilidades especiales tienen
sus propias rutinas y técnicas y
tácticas y hábitos para avanzar a pesar
de lo que se interponga pero por sobre
todo tiene una actitud de enfoque en su
elemento en lo que les gusta hacer muy
pero muy particular
yo le digo que es como si fueran
karatecas pero karatecas mentales y creo
que es exactamente eso lo que les
permite superar los obstáculos que
aparecen siempre en el camino de quien
quiere hacer cosas
es así como poco a poco fui encontrando
una misteriosa relación entre el kárate
y el mundo de las ideas una relación que
me permitiría a mí también hacer karate
con mi creatividad
y hoy quiero compartir algunas técnicas
pero empecemos por el principio
karate 2 significa el camino de la mano
vacía y esto es así en parte porque
originalmente el carácter on arte
marcial practicada por campesinos que
tenían prohibidas las armas entonces
tenían que arreglárselas con lo que
tenían sus manos y sus piernas pero con
lo que tenían desarrollaron destrezas y
habilidades y una disciplina cuyo
propósito fundamental es el conocimiento
de uno mismo lo cual me hace acordar
mucho al camino de la creatividad en el
cual cuanto más uno lo recorre más se
conoce a uno mismo y más descubre que
con lo que tiene puede crear mucho más
de lo que imagina
se dice que el propósito del carácter es
no tener que usarlo nunca pero en el
caso de que fuera necesario el karateca
puede apelar algunas de las siguientes
tres estrategias
evitar la confrontación
cambiar la perspectiva y actuar para
desactivar el obstáculo
evitar la confrontación significa no ir
nunca al choque de lo que se nos opone
sino más bien dejarlos ser y hacerlo
formar parte de lo que estamos creando
entonces por ejemplo se nos derramó
pintura en el cuadro que estamos
pintando bueno intentamos hacer que la
mancha forme parte de la obra o estamos
grabando una canción con la guitarra y
tocamos la nota incorrecta bueno nos
fijamos si esa nota no puede formar
parte de un nuevo arreglo o se nos borró
el último capítulo de la novela que
estábamos escribiendo
quien te dice no es una buena
oportunidad para repensar esa sección
cuando hacemos que los obstáculos formen
parte de lo que estamos creando todo el
proceso se enriquece porque los
obstáculos añaden elementos inesperados
que pueden ser muy pero muy creativos
entonces en lugar de confrontar los de
enojarnos de frustrar nos de bajar los
brazos los hacemos parte del plan y eso
es exactamente lo que haría un karateca
usar la energía del oponente a su favor
a partir de ahí podemos cambiar la
perspectiva la segunda estrategia del
carácter frente a una oponente el
carácter a lo que va a buscar
generalmente es moverse hacia los
laterales cambiar de eje porque desde
los laterales puede ver mejor lo que no
ve de frente
eso en creatividad suele llamarse
pensamiento lateral y es una estrategia
que te permite descubrir posibilidades a
través de ir variando ligeramente el
enfoque de las cosas una forma muy
efectiva de ejercitar el pensamiento
lateral es por ejemplo a través de la
formulación de preguntas entonces la
próxima vez que aparezca un problema o
un obstáculo en tu camino creativo nos
preguntamos
qué me está queriendo decir este
problema y cuál es la oportunidad que se
oculta detrás de este obstáculo que se
me está apareciendo aquí y si no es tan
grande de estar tan grave como parece y
la más importante de todas como lo
resolvería superman
todas las preguntas valen y todas las
preguntas te pueden llevar a explorar un
camino cuyo destino puede ser muy pero
muy creativo por eso cada pregunta que
te hagas es una especie de moverte hacia
los laterales como el karateka
desde los laterales el karateca también
tiene un mejor acceso a los puntos
débiles del oponente la tercera
estrategia de karate que encuentro muy
valiosa para el mundo de las ideas
porque sabes una cosa
todos los obstáculos tienen un punto
débil
si todos los obstáculos tienen un punto
débil capaz de desactivarlo o de al
menos dejarnos avanzar a pesar de él y
justamente porque son puntos débiles no
requieren de grandes dosis de esfuerzo
por parte de nuestra sino que más bien
son una táctica una pequeña acción que
tiene el poder de hacer que aquello que
te parecía insorteable se desmorone por
si mismo
la clave es buscarlo y actuar
un ejemplo el famoso bloqueo creativo la
hoja en blanco está ahí y no se nos
ocurre que escribir tenemos dos opciones
si nos la quedamos mirando la hoja se
nos va a hacer cada vez más grande la
otra opción es salir a buscar el punto
débil de ese bloqueo creativo entonces
acordate pequeñas acciones escribimos
frases cortas de lo que sea de lo que
sentimos de lo que vemos a nuestro
alrededor de lo que pensamos aunque no
nos guste lo que salga escribimos por el
solo hecho de actuar y si hacemos este
ejercicio es muy probable que alguna de
las cosas que hayamos escrito nos
conecten un poquito más y nos inviten a
desarrollarlas un poquito más en ese
momento habremos dado con el punto débil
y es muy probable que podamos seguir
avanzando
lo importante es recordar que nunca
nadie supera un obstáculo de brazos
cruzados la clave es actuar pero para
hacerlo siempre es bueno tener la
mentalidad correcta no una especie de
filosofía del enfoque creativo que te
ayuda a tomar decisiones y en ese
sentido el karate también tiene algunas
ideas para aportarnos
mira
mente de principiante
el karateca cuando entra al 2o aunque
sea cinturón negro lo hace siempre en
actitud de aprender algo nuevo y
nosotros también cuando entramos al
espacio de nuestras ideas de nuestra
creatividad podemos hacerlo en actitud
de aprender algo nuevo incluso a través
de los problemas y de los obstáculos
mente de principiante es un recordatorio
y una invitación a ejercitar la
curiosidad siempre
otro enfoque el cinturón negro que a
diferencia de lo que muchos piensan no
es el fin no es que uno practica karate
para llegar a cinturón negro sino que es
un comienzo más porque el carácter así
como el camino creativo es un juego
infinito no termina nunca y eso
significa que van a ver ideas y van a
ver obstáculos pero ni las ideas ni los
obstáculos definen el juego sino que
siempre se trata acerca de nosotros
mismos y nuestra capacidad para tomar lo
que suma eludir lo que no y seguir
avanzando en dirección hacia nuestras
ideas para poder crearlas y crecer a
través de ellas
el día que hayamos realizado nuestro
proyecto nos ponemos el cinturón negro
no hay ningún problema pero eso no
significa que hayamos terminado porque
siempre va a ser el comienzo de algo más
y la última que
ese grito que hacen los karatecas cuando
dan un golpe bueno ese grito significa
la unión de toda la energía porque el
karateca sabe que sea el momento de dar
un golpe toda su energía está enfocada
hacia un mismo punto el impacto va a ser
mayor y del mismo modo si al momento de
trabajar en nuestras ideas todos
nuestros esfuerzos están enfocados hacia
un mismo propósito el impacto de
nuestras acciones va a ser mayor
y así uno puede ir haciendo un poco de
karate con la mente para sintonizar con
su creatividad tener ideas trabajar en
ellas y poderlos poder superar los
obstáculos que aparecen siempre en el
camino de quien hace cosas
tres estrategias del carácter que nos
ayudan a seguir avanzando evitar la
confrontación cambiar la perspectiva y
actuar para desactivar el obstáculo y
tres enfoques que nos ayudan a tomar
decisiones creativas
mente de principiante recordar que el
juego no tiene fin y tratar de enfocar
nuestros esfuerzos hace un mismo
propósito cada vez que nos sea posible
eso es lo que intento hacer desde aquel
día en que el doc me dijo esa frase
la energía viene de hacer las cosas que
te entusiasman
recuerdo que cuando salí del consultorio
fui a mi casa y quería investigar la
etimología de la palabra entusiasmo
entonces abrí el diccionario y le di que
significa algo así como tener un dios
adentro o estar lleno de un fuego que te
enciende y te anima a hacer grandes
cosas entusiasmo
en un mundo en el que muchas veces se
nos quiere hacer creer que ya está todo
inventado que es más fácil consumir que
crear y que para qué animarnos si
podemos fallar no no me llama la
atención que también haya una pandemia
de abandono de ideas de desgano y de
frustración por eso creo que sintonizar
contra nuestra creatividad tener ideas
dejar que nos enciendan y hacer un
poquito de karate con la mente cada vez
que aparezca un obstáculo es tan pero
tan importante para vivir
porque la energía viene de hacer las
cosas que te entusiasman
gracias doc
os
[Música]